The Joe Rogan Experience I think there's
a lot of functional people that run out
I think Trump dog was flying he was on
some something Trump was flying on
something I think a lot of people are
doing that Dave Portnoy is pretty open
about it he told me he did it before the
podcast yeah and he seemed totally
normal yeah but he's like if I don't
have it I just feel like I don't have my
Edge really yeah doesn't it like I heard
it shrinks here like while you're high
on it
gone dude yeah it turns like gray yeah
it's gone oh dude like a cocaine thing
almost worse because adderall's all day
your dick is dude your dick is this I
take Adderall sometimes just to get
[ __ ] up it's fun to drink on dude you
take Adderall you can drink all day you
can drink all day anyway no but I'll go
like I'll go all right I'll take
adderall and drink until my body shuts
down but because of the Adderall you're
still there like all we went to the
World Series
Phillies Astros World Series I was
blacked out but I was fully like
what's going on then we tried to leave
the stadium and I was like
yo
[Laughter]
I can't stay I left I couldn't walk yeah
it's like in Call of Duty when your
character dies but you get the camera to
float around them if you take Adderall
you can Day drink because I don't yeah I
get crazy I can't drink on Adderall how
often do you take it that was the two
times I've taken it damn sorry Notre
Dame World Series it's a big day if I'm
taking Adderall it's a big that dude
what's up
whoever I'm with there's always somebody
around that is prescribed yeah it's 10
to 12 I would say it's like 10 to 20.
it's crazy yeah 10 to 20 milligrams
probably 10 to 20 to sometimes you get
you run into people that are like 30
[ __ ] 40 milligrams crunch of time
release Google December I think porno I
said he took takes a 30. yeah I was like
I didn't bring it up I was like that's a
lot some people Munch the time release
too they have little balls you can crack
down on them and just get it all at once
I tried to snort those things
plastic balls oh dude I I try to it's
crazy I tried drinking on it twice the
one time I was I was in college I tried
to I was on the Adderall I didn't
realize even like what it was I was
drinking on it I got all zoomed out and
I was like at the kind of a not like a
super high level of a concert and I was
like I'm gonna jump down to the next
level and I try to jump down and I got
kicked out immediately
[ __ ] up it was [ __ ] up yeah I was
like if I could time it perfectly where
all the guards backs are turned I'll
jump down to the pit climb up and jump
into like the other area you're trying
to get it up to the stage it just
snagged me yeah of course I snagged me
you're a mess I'll jump into the crowd
I'll blend and the crowd just parted as
I jumped into them the guy just beat the
[ __ ] I was out of South Carolina
South Carolina
knocked my one shoe off I got back in
with one I kicked mother shoe off so I
didn't look suspicious so I walked in in
my socks and they thought my friend was
me and they started kicking him out and
I was like I just thought it happened I
was like [ __ ] it my friend had to get
kicked out and then I got kicked out
again and then I snuck back in a third
time yeah no lie in my Tom Cruise this
is Mission Impossible I was on Adderall
that's why I cannot drink on Adderall I
snuck in I would do it I snuck in with
the Aramark workers I just walked in
with them only in my socks and I climbed
up through under the bleachers and I
just emerged into like some seating
people like ah
you're gonna appreciate this sneaking at
a stadium I was
gone it was an all-day tailgate I was at
South Carolina First Tennessee SEC
football it's a night game in South
Carolina and I'm standing there and
there's just a tiny fence between me and
the handicap section
and I literally I just stepped over it
no one no one better than I do I was
standing there just
I was all in the field I left my friends
they were in the student section
faced walking around I was like
stepped in and dude people were like
looking at me like checks out
fully checked out
[Laughter]
this guy he's by himself someone just
brought you a blanket thanks man
oh my God it happened at uh you get like
that
yeah
dude
I'm just picturing you shoot your face
that's some guy doing a handicap track
I was at the Bills game Bill Steelers
this year uh and Gabe Davis he's a wide
receiver he likes comedy and he likes
podcasts and all this stuff so he
invited me to the game I'm at the game
and I took at it all there there you go
there's another Adderall uh end of the
game
he's like come down here towards the
field he took his jersey off
autographed it and handed it to me up in
the stands whoa dude it's just me and
children me and little kids are the only
dudes like down there trying to get high
fives from the players this guy hands me
his jersey and people are like oh that's
a
it's a guy especially like NFL films was
filming it like it was it was like a
sweet moment for them to be giving me a
jersey and I was like
it was just me and children dude it was
me and children in the bleachers like
high five can I get your gloves good
game
and then the guy gave me his jersey and
they're like nice congratulations yeah
like that's what that's what it's all
about